[Music]
hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how would you raise your abilities as a
competitive game
I've always classed myself as mediocre
the most average player in the lobby
my aim is substandard my reactions
distinctly average but I want to be good
at apex legends so I've been fine-tuning
the settings on console and I'm
delighted to say I found seven subtle
changes which will bridge the gap to the
pros and let even the most casual of
players compete for victory without
putting thirty hours a week in here's an
example when transitioning into apex
legends the old me could get the job
done but it was a train wreck of over
adjustment when aiming but now with my
updated settings my aim is reliable from
the first shot and stays on target far
easier so at last I'm not the weakest
player in the squad as our
let's start with sensitivity because
most of us just want to know what each
other is playing on what sensitivity
does everyone use initially I was
tempted to use a high sense due to
playing fortnight for the last year but
we need to get that mentality out of our
head quickly apex Legends rewards
consistent accuracy and although some
players will prosper at high cents the
majority will not small adjustments are
king here my suggestion is to up the
default sensitivity slightly to number 4
named high we are doing this for two
reasons
firstly this will give you enough speed
to dodge enemy fire and make yourself a
harder target to hit overall generally
increasing maneuverability but the
second reason is to retain control of
the ping system
this is our lifeline to teammates no pun
intended this is a team shooter for a
reason and sacrificing precision for
speed isn't the right thing to do
especially with such a prolonged time to
kill today
ex legends so we have our general sense
sorted but history shows us a slightly
slower aiming-down-sights sensitivity is
required to keep our shots on target in
your settings keep the ad S as default
which is number three because we've
already moved the general sensitivity up
this will automatically feel slower when
aiming down sights making mid-range to
long-range bites easier to keep enemies
in your reticle here's something I still
need to work on in close-up scenarios
try to use hipfire to maintain the speed
I'm still working on this but my muscle
memory forces me to aim before every
shot but one day I will get there and
I'm sure you'll master it before I do
the next step is surprisingly important
under AD s we have a response curve I
didn't really have a clue what this
meant so I tested things out for a while
the classic setting mirrors tighten
fault whose aiming or if you didn't play
that game it feels like how Modern
Warfare felt back in 2007 what happens
is as you move the reticle there is a
slight moment before the input it's
probably accepted by the console so
basically it's slowed down for a split
second whilst you start to move this is
primarily here to make tiny adjustments
in gunfights but secondly when done
correctly it feels like the weapon has
legitimate weight to it this is how the
human body actually works let's say
you're picking something off a table but
it's heavy for a millisecond while your
muscles figure out how much energy to
assert you pick up that item slower as
soon as your brain understands the
weight of the object you once again move
at top speed this is how response curves
work in video games on the other side of
the spectrum is linear and this setting
has no response curve at all the exact
movement of your thumb on the controller
happens in the game
those people with unbelievable quick
reactions who can play at high speed
will use this or a slightly easier
version called high velocity which now
brings us to the one I suggest steady
this is perfection in my eyes acting the
same as classic setting a steady aim
adds a little more of a ramp up to full
speed making two tiny adjustments at
long medium range even easier but when
it comes to throwing down ridiculous
amounts of bullets the steady curve
acceleration kicks in at the same time
as the weapon begins to recoil giving
you the ability to control the weapon
direction in addition to those tiny
adjustments weapons legitimately feel
heavier in this mode more lifelike
rather than like nerf guns please give
it a try I would love to know your
thoughts the next setting is dead zone
the best way to understand this is by
holding out your thumb now try to keep
it as still as you can however much you
try your hand will slightly move it's
impossible our heartbeat means that we
are always moving dead zones on
controllers are here in part to ignore
small movements in our thumbs another
reason why dead zones are important
comes down to wear and tear in your
controller over time your thumb sticks
will begin to lean to one side causing
your character to slowly walk in that
die
you have a few choices in this scenario
fix your controller buy a new one or
change the dead zone settings to tell
the console to ignore that imperfection
long story shot use small dead zones as
default or even none if you have a
controller under 18 months old and of
course have full control over your
thumbs unlike me
oh wait while we're here turn off
vibration yeah it's great and all but it
disrupts your control and disaffection
completely it'll also stop you saying ow
when someone shoots you in-game why do
we do that the next setting is another
game changer PC players have had this
for years but only a handful of console
games have this option field of view in
the video settings it's possible to
change your perspective from 70 degrees
to a whopping 110 degrees just look at
this difference look how much more you
can see on either side I have mine set
between 90 and 100 depending on how far
I sit from the screen and it's important
to know why here's an example it may
appear that maxing out this setting will
be the best option as you can see much
more of the battlefield but it
completely depends on what engagements
you're planning for and if you're
playing sat on a couch 2 meters away
from a 50-inch TV or sat at a desk with
a 24-inch monitor in front of your eyes
let's quickly break that down look at
the target in the distance at 70 degrees
of vision it's easy to track and rather
large target to aim for here's the same
thing at 110 degrees a much smaller
target and if you're sat far away from
the screen this is simply impossible to
hit I personally recommend between 90
and 100 for players playing close to the
screen or 70 to 80 for those in their
front room sat a meter or two away from
the action
oh there's another great thing about
widening the viewpoint it's feel the
entire game feels quicker you feel
superhuman ultra responsive just
remember not to overdo it or you'll be
useless to your team at range let's
quickly talk about button remapping and
that slide function without a doubt is a
beast which you'll use in and out of
battle I recommend anyone using a
standard controller to switch to the
setting button puncher this will remap
the melee and Crouch slide buttons
meaning that right thumbstick becomes
Crouch when pressed allowing you to keep
both thumb's on the sticks more often if
you have a pro controller or play cloth
it's regardless but for us mortals
button puncher is awesome let's quickly
look at audio or would it be listen to
audio just jump into audio settings if
you want to be competitive audio is key
so if you're playing without a headset
you're at a major disadvantage you are
not hearing the three-dimensional sound
but if you do have a headset you can
adjust things to get a little extra edge
although the music in apex is great it's
it's hugely distracting and can hide
'important audio queues I recommend
either lowering those settings are
completely switching them off the sound
of gunfire will quickly become the music
to your ears make sure your sound
effects are at full whack and depending
on your preference it's a good idea to
lower the dialogue option but I won't do
that because I love to hear this guy
spamming 12 grenades in a row
show my comrades look joke so there we
have it seven settings to make an
average APEC Legends player compete
against those people who have no life
I mean compete against those people who
wanted the pros I do hope this was
helpful in some way I am Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time